Livan so long well obviously is because
the people who are getting advice from
doctors are getting inappropriate advice
if the advice that doctors were giving
was correct then there should be a lot
of people living to be 100 who follow
the doctor's advice so we're gonna look
at some of that first thing I wanted to
do is get some scientific evidence of on
what it would take to live to be 100 and
I look for an animal model being a
veterinarian and a pathologist I look
for an animal model first and I ran into
doing some research I ran into some
stuff that was published in the 1860s
1863 one was written by William Banting
on how to cure corpulence corpulence is
an old-timey word for obesity and this
was back in 1863 he talked about a
low-carb diet
kind of like the head cannot maybe it
should be the Banting diet you know
instead of the camtonz diet and then in
1935 I have a guy who had been doing all
his research in the 1920s by the name of
Clive McKay came out with his landmark
article in 1935 and what he did was
essentially take three groups around
Scruton umber one he gave the rat pellet
of the day and these rats lived to be an
average of two years which is really
super because part of this rat pellet
coming out with all of the nutritional
knowledge of the time people who are
using rats and mice and rabbits for
research who would give them rolled oats
and carrots and cabbage and things like
that they might live to be 11 months
after weaning instead of two years so
it's really good to have a laboratory
animal and a food that you could give
them that routinely allowed them to live
b2 he then took a second group gave him
the same basic pellet as group number
one but he cut the carbohydrate calories
by 30 percent kept the vitamins and
minerals the same and they lived to be
50 percent older three years got kind of
excited about that took group number
three kept the carbohydrate calories
from group number one by 60% kept the
vitamins minerals the same and they live
twice as long they live to be four years
of age and they really got excited about
cutting this carbohydrate calories thing
yeah but it wasn't just that when they
redid the studies with spiders and
beetles and worms and pigeons and all
kinds of animals they found out that it
was the density of the vitamins and
minerals per remaining carbohydrate
calorie that was the the basic reason
because he had always kept the vitamins
and minerals the same when he dropped
the calories he doesn't
didn't just drop the percentage of food
he dropped only the carbohydrate
calories keeping everything else the
same
so in group number three there was like
three times more vitamins minerals per
carbohydrate calories than it was a
group number one now that I had an
animal model and had some idea what to
do I began to look for a human model and
I ran into a guy by name art Linkletter
how many of you heard of art Linkletter
okay
great guy he was funny he and I put he
and Jack Benny and Red Skelton and
Milton Berle on same thing same group
they could tell funny stories without
saying dirty words and things and great
family comedians and art Linkletter
wanted to live to be a hundred and he
wanted to live to be a hundred because
he read this book was a Pulitzer Prize
winning book published in 1933 called
Lost Horizon it was written by James
Hilton and in this book Lost Horizon
James Hilton coined the term shangri-la
I'm you're heard of shangri-la okay les
where that came from that book and art
Linkletter got it real excited about
living to be a hundred well the book was
actually written about a a people called
the Huns of how many of you heard of the
Huns ins
okay well the honza's come from
northeast of Pakistan and their
third-world country obviously and and
art Linkletter hired an eye doctor by
the name Alan Banach dr. Alan Banach and
this eye doctor was kind of an amateur
farmer and an art Linkletter funded him
to go there for six months during the
growing season and find out what their
secret was living the 100 and it was
very obvious from reading the book that
Alan Banach had not read Clive McKay's
material on his rats and he was just
making lots of observations didn't give
his opinion what was important but he
was a very good observer and one of the
things he found out there these people
were a third world country they had no
electricity no indoor plumbing no
hospitals no pharmacies no clinics no
doctors they just used home remedies
like herbs and massage therapy and that
sort of thing and yet they were the
healthiest and longest lived people on
earth they came from a little mountain
range a little known mountain range by
the name of the Karakoram mountains
about 800 miles east of the Himalayans
oftentimes people say they're from the
himalayas but they're from the camera
character room mountains and one of the
things dr. Banach observed was that they
would irrigate with water
it was kind of gray and opaque it had
lots of silt in it from the glacier
grinding up the mountain rocks and they
would irrigate with this glacial water
full this rock silt is finally ground up
rock silt about the same particle size
as talc and it contained over 60
minerals and it would irrigate with this
and as the water percolated down into
their fields and their gardens it left a
half inch to one inch of this gray silt
on top of the soil and before it dried
they would run out with their hose and
rakes they would hoe and rake the silt
down into the soil before it blew away
now these people lived at the nineteen
thousand five hundred foot level
nineteen thousand five hundred feet you
can't grow corn and potatoes and rice
okay they could grow wheat and rye and
barley but because of the very short
growing season their yields were very
very tiny
they're only carbohydrate viii during
the day the only carbohydrate the age
during the day was a little tortilla one
tortilla add a little turkey a little
round flatbread that was it no other
carbohydrate the majority of their food
was a goat and lamb and mutton and in
camel and and things like yak and
rabbits and they'd get some wild sheep
and goats in the area they eat chickens
and and eggs they didn't have fish in
those areas are too high up for fish and
so they and they cooked in butter they
use milk and cheese and yogurt they
could Storch dairy protein as cheese and
yogurt and that was it they had a little
garden they grow a little bit of cabbage
and tomatoes nothing else it would also
take the wood ashes from their fires or
cooking and heating fires and put it in
their gardens how many vebber put wood
ashes from a fire in your garden yeah
this is a very old European and an Asian
custom and somehow somebody learned that
by putting the wood ashes from your
fires in your gardens it increases the
yields and makes the food taste better
and so forth well it turns out the wood
ashes are the minerals that are left
when you burn away the carbon in the
wood so now I had not only an animal
model but a human model they had a
renewable source of minerals in their
food they were on a low carbohydrate
diet and to me it seemed it explained
why they lived to be a ripe old age and
we're very productive I also began to
collect birth
the announcements and obituaries of
people who live to be a hundred I wanted
to see really what happened to people
they live to be a hundred so I'll show
you a few ralph Charles from Somerset
Ohio about in the middle of the state
back in October of 1999 turned a hundred
they had a nice little newspaper article
about him and told his story the
fascinating thing to me about ralph
Charles was that at age 100 he was still
piloting charter flights and carrying
paying passengers around the central
part of the United States
he used his single-engine Arrancar
aircraft he didn't have any restrictions
on his health papers or his license now
to me he doesn't look like what you
would expect a decrepit 100 year old to
look like to me he's very vibrant he
looks like his maybe in his late 70s or
early 80s and he's a hundred years old
and still pouting I mean can imagine if
he had alzheimers disease he'd get up
there and he'd say excuse me ma'am where
are we going that make you nervous with
it but he didn't have those problems
obviously a few ladies I'm gonna throw
in Connie Douglas Reeves back in
September of 2002 she turned 101 when
she turned 101 September 26 2002 she was
inducted into the cowgirl Hall of Fame
and her personal motto was always saddle
your own horse and to me she looks like
one of those feisty little people that
wouldn't listen to a doctor you know
she's got her thumbs in her belt she's
got her shoulders back her chins out you
can just imagine a doctor saying to her
look Connie here 101 years old now it's
time to give up salt we got to worry
about your blood pressure it's time to
give up eggs and butter we got to worry
about your cholesterol and she's gonna
say well I piers docked and I've been
eating salt and butter since before we
were born and eggs before you're born
I'm not gonna give that up you can just
see her she is not a shrinking violet
for those of you they're a little more
genteel in May of 2001 this fellow here
Harold Stillson from Deerfield Beach
Florida turned 101 went out and played
golf for his birthday and he hit a six
pole in one at 101 now you have to have
a strong grip you have to be able to see
108 yards you know you have to have good
eye hand coordination you have to have a
good memory you can't have a Lesar
disease you mesh and getting that golf
club up there and saying
is this baseball I mean what am I doing
here right and so he's color-coordinated
it doesn't get any better than that for
a hundred one years old I think he looks
pretty good for a hundred and one in
this fella Antonio Todd from Sardinia
the island formerly island nation west
of the mainland of Italy back in January
of 2001 turned 112 and he attributed his
longevity to drinking one glass of red
wine a day there's a certain amount of
validity to that because in the red wine
there these antioxidants that we know
reduce your risk of heart disease and
cancer we can get those same
antioxidants and fruits and vegetables
so you don't need to drink the wine
necessarily it doesn't seem to matter
what you eat as long as you keep the
carbohydrates down and the vitamins and
minerals up that seems to be the thread
the common thread between all hundred
year olds I'll show an example this gal
here door Rama Thievery from South
Africa was born in 1881 and in 1995 she
turned 114 when she was asked Dora what
do you attribute your health and
longevity to she said oh wait locusts
you know the grasshoppers you know about
grasshoppers here right pumpkin seeds
tortoise meat wild herbs dried fruit in
a cup of coffee you notice it doesn't
say bread you notice it doesn't say
potatoes doesn't say rice doesn't say
corn the only carbohydrate might be a
little bit of that dried fruit she got
her protein from the locusts from the
grasshoppers and the tortoise meat she
got her essential fatty acids from the
pumpkin seeds and if she ate the herbs
grain she got a little bit of vitamin C
and folic acid and beta carotene and she
lived to be 114 she probably lived
longer than that I didn't keep track of
her after that birthday announcement
yeah crickets won't work okay February
15th 2003 this gal here Maddie
Owens 119 at age 119 and she grew up in
the South Carolina and apparently when
she was born in 1883 she was still
working in the cotton fields Owens told
her family of her hard work in the
cotton fields I guarantee you that she
didn't have vaccinations I guarantee
that she didn't have antibiotics I
guarantee if she didn't have three good
square meals a day but I'll betcha
because I spent a lot of time in Africa
two years in Africa and I know what they
did with her wood ashes from their
cooking fires I always put it in their
gardens even in Africa for their cabbage
and their tomatoes and beans and so
forth and so I bet that her parents put
the wood ashes from her cooking fires
into the gardens and one of my favorite
birthday announcements goes back to 1995
this was a birth announcement for Jeanne
Calment from France and she was
documented by the Guinness World Book of
Records being the oldest living woman at
the time there was more than 200 women
who claimed to be older than she they
didn't have the paperwork to prove it
Jeanne Calment had the paperwork to
prove to the satisfaction of the
Guinness World Book of Records that
February 21st 1995 she was in fact 120
every 21st 1996 she turned 121 feb 24
1997 sharing 122 and she died in August
of 1997 at age 120 two years in a
hundred and sixty four days she died
suddenly of a stroke she was up cooking
her eggs and singing frère Jacques fell
over dead didn't have Alzheimers disease
she's Bryant mentally alert until the
moment she died she didn't have
cardiovascular disease she didn't have
diabetes she didn't have cancer and she
did have rheumatoid arthritis in her
hands you can see that's pretty good
live to be 120 two and a half died
suddenly without being mentally infirm I
mean that's the way to do it right I
thought this wasn't kind of cute I was
in Adelaide Australia back in October of
2003 when this came out in Australian
newspaper world's oldest man dies at 122
a Cambodian tagging tiger hunter
by the name of sec yi who is also that
martial arts expert attributed his
longevity and that of his wife i'm
assuming a widow now long hook on her
nate to smoking in prayer that's kind of
a strange combination but I'm sure he
had got some mineral somewhere
again this is an Australian newspaper
came out in March of 2003 a Brazilian
beat believed to be the world's oldest
woman died at age 124 Maria Etta Lavina
dos Santos died of a stroke her birth
certificate says she was the descendant
of African slaves born in July of 1878
do you think she got vaccinations and
antibiotics seems she had three good
square meals a day no she was born in a
straw hut caulked with cow dung
I probably led a pretty miserable life
as she was growing up but I guarantee
you they put their would ashes from
their cooking fires into the gardens
they didn't have doctors and they didn't
have hospitals and clinics and they
didn't have pharmaceuticals and she
lived 124 I'll give you two more than I
think you'll get the idea and then we'll
move on I think these are interesting
and they all tell stories the other one
want to talk about briefly is a 1997
study by the Health Insurance
Association of America found that 75
percent of insurance fraud is committed
by providers which is their code word
for doctors seventy-five percent of
health fraud health insurance fraud is
committed by doctors who apply for
payment which they get for procedures
they didn't even do they apply for
payment for procedures they give you
that you didn't need they're the only
profession or trade in America or the
world where they don't have to go to a
bank with any extra money they just send
it in a couple of claims an insurance
company insurance company pays them they
don't even there's not a single doctor
ever goes to jail for that insurance
companies write that off as the cost of
doing business now who pays for that
each and every one of us as these
premiums go up as more and more doctors
or
these things and they look at it as hey
it's our money we're gonna get it anyway
we we have to this came out in September
of 1997 was an article published in the
journal the American Medical Association
young doctors lacked stethoscope skills
which is you know the primary instrument
of a doctor many new doctors steeped in
hi-tech medicine can't properly use a
stethoscope what they learned was they
could just identify 20% they could just
identified 20% of heart problems that
were presented to them they could not
identify 80% so how could you go to
school for 14 years not use a
stethoscope like a apprentice carpenter
apprentice thing for seven years how can
you not learn how to use a hammer right
well the reason why doctors don't spend
any time learning how to use a
stethoscope is because if they were to
use a stethoscope to diagnose
cardiovascular problems and by the way
ladies and gentlemen you can identify
all cardiovascular problems with a
stethoscope it takes you an extra 10
minutes to listen to every square
millimeter the heart and the valves and
the arteries and things but you can do
it gain the skills to do it but then you
make an extra 30 bucks for a long office
visit but if they send you in they send
you in for an angiogram or I can't scan
an MRI or an ultrasound guess what
they make 421 dollars every time they
send somebody in for those procedures
what's better 421 bucks or 30 bucks hmm
okay you're beginning to get a picture
develop here now this happens this
happens 3,000 times a year in America
Mildred C Clark 86 years old was found
cold stiff and blue on her apartment
floor and the apartment manager got
scared because he thought she was dead
so he called the paramedics and they
examine yeah she's dead and so they
called the coroner he came out yeah
she's dead so they put in a body bag and
ship her to the Albany knee art Medical
Center which was associated with medical
school there in upstate New York and
they sent an intern down to do the final
exam before they got a death certificate
honor because you can't do an autopsy on
somebody until they've had a desert very
good so he examines her and he probably
just closed his eyes ever seen a dead
body by himself right so he oh well
everybody else says she's dead so he
writes his death certificate they take
her down to the morgue and they strip
her naked take a pressure hose blow all
her makeup and gunk off her body
put her wet naked body into the body bag
and they put her in a freezer for 90
minutes until the medical examiner and
the pathologist get there to do the
autopsy 90 minutes after being in the
freezer they wheel her out and sip open
the body bag and Mildred C Clark 86
years old sits up she says thank God you
found me it was cold and dark in there
and I didn't know where it was
I mean after 14 years of medical school
doctors can't even tell if you're alive
or dead that makes me nervous and then
according to Ralph Nader in January of
1993 big study coroner Ralph Nader
doctors kill each year in America
300,000 patients in hospitals alone each
year as a result of medical negligence
300,000 are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence each year in America 1.3
million Americans are injured in
hospitals as a result of medical
negligence each year in America 2
million are infected in hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence and
despite heroic round-the-clock nursing
care and intravenous antibiotics 90,000
100,000 these 2 million each year died
in hospitals each year 2.2 million
people get what's called adverse drug
reactions and the drugs that they are
introduced to in the hospital
and despite heroic measures 140 thousand
to two hundred thousand Diary or you add
these up ladies and gentlemen that's 3.5
million to 4 million casualties killed
injured and infected each year and
hustles by doctors each year 3.5 million
to 4 million
old injured and infected each year in
hospitals by doctors it's estimated to
be double that outside of hospitals now
we're not talking about three people a
year here we're talking about a huge
number of people so why do we go to
doctors for health and longevity
information in 1999 doctors were
believed to be the not eighth top killer
of Americans medical mistakes were the
eighth top killer of Americans behind
cardiovascular disease cancer diabetes
Alzheimer's disease gastrointestinal
problems liver problems kidney problems
and doctors today this is just out I
haven't had time to make a slide but
trust me right now doctors each year in
America killed just short of 800,000
people they're now listed as the number
one cause of death in Americans number
two is cardiovascular disease number
three is cancer
number one or doctor kills okay now how
do we deal with this even even Thomas
Jefferson said that a little revolution
once was a good thing it's time to
revolt against the American healthcare
system they do everything in their favor
nothing in the favor of the patients
it's a miracle
it's a god-given miracle if you survive
a hospital visit truly not being damaged
or infected or killed and so how do we
deal with this well we've learned in
other instances how to deal with these
kind of problems when the industry is
abusing us for instance 60 years ago
when the automobile industry began to
abuse customers you know you go in for a
six dollar oil change 60 years ago and
you go to pick up your car that's it
well it's 300 bucks you say wow that's
my month's wages what do you mean 300
bucks well you told us to do whatever is
necessary and so we rebuilt your
transmission we rebuilt your carburetor
we gave you all new tires we rotated
them we put in a new brake shoes new
spark plugs we gapped them we did your
timing 300 bucks and you kicked the
counter and yelled and screamed but in
the end you paid your 300 bucks
well people got tired of that and so
they started going to flea markets and
junkyards and garage sales looking for
parts for their car and after a while
the demand for these parts and tools it
garage sales and flea markets and junk
became so great these sources couldn't
handle the demand anymore so a whole
industry popped up how many ever heard
of NAPA Auto Parts and Pep Boys an
autozone and Shooks hmm and because now
you can walk in you can get any part you
want you can get any tool you want for
working on your own car this has turned
out to be a huge industry and that's
because the honorable industry got
greedy some 60 years ago now more people
do it themselves and the same thing
happened in the construction industry
when it got to the point where they're
charging a little a couple 60 bucks to
change the float in the toilet and two
hundred dollars to change the light bulb
and the you know little couples would
sign a contract for six thousand dollar
roof but they didn't point out to them
that there is a rotating interest thing
or revolving interesting and if you
didn't pay it in a year it cost you a
hundred thousand dollars and all these
horror stories came out so people began
to go to junkyards and garage sales and
flea markets looking for materials and
tools to maintain repair their own homes
how do you remember back in the 50s and
60s when everybody had a table saw and a
bandsaw and routers and all these tools
you turned your garage into a shop but
everybody began to do things themselves
well soon these sources couldn't supply
the demand anymore so a whole industry
developed to supply the demand for
people who want to maintain repair their
own homes are called Home Depot and
Lowe's and Menards and if you don't know
how to put shingles on your own roof
they'll give you a free class okay
well it's long overdue that we repeal in
the same way against the healthcare
industry and you do more and more self
with a little bit of education 15
minutes of reading a night listening to
tapes or CDs in your drive around your
car in any particular instance with 15
minutes of reading you can do whatever a
doctor does is that simple for instance
a doctor has less than a hundred dollars
worth of stuff in his examining room
he's got a blood pressure cuff a
stethoscope
he's got a thermometer a little rubber
mallet to see if you have reflexes with
you walk in the exam room I know you got
reflexes now if they carry in I might
want to test them but if you're walking
on your own you're singing and dance and
I don't don't worry about that too much
they have a little triple-a battery pen
light you know they look in your eyes
and down your throat with and that was
given to them by some salesman for a
pharmaceutical company jerk another
pocket look at it and you'll see all
right look at that Pfizer
okay so they have less than a hundred
bucks for the stuff you can go to a
pharmacy or a grocery store and buy all
that stuff yourself without
description with the exception of
ultrasound and radiation and Kant scans
and MRIs you can get just about any test
that a doctor would send you to a lab or
Hospital for for instance you can go and
you can buy a little bottle of test
strips to find out what your blood sugar
and blood cholesterol is you can get
little test strips to find out if you
have blood or sugar in your urine you
can get test strips it's final if you
have blood in your bowel movement to do
a screen for colon cancer and all sort
of colitis maybe gastric ulcers you can
find out if you're pregnant or not for
19.95 and get a little test strip you
pee on it and you find out if you're
pregnant 30 seconds honey I'm pregnant
kind of thing right 30 seconds nineteen
ninety five you don't have to go get a
physical exam get a blood test they
charge 150 bucks and then you got to
come back in three days for another
hundred fifty bucket so it winds up
being like five hundred dollars to find
out if you're pregnant or not you can do
for 1995 the one that I really find
disgusting are the fertility clinics you
have to pay 25 thousand bucks up front
for they even talk to you because they
might slip and give you a little
information so before the doctor will
see you you got to pay your twenty five
thousand bucks and then they'll start
talking to you about what they can do to
help you in a situation of infertility
well they want you to believe that they
are the holders of all knowledge in this
well back when I was a kid my dad only
you know sixty years ago
my dad only had a fourth-grade education
and he knew how to artificially
inseminate cattle back then there's not
a new thing we've been doing it
livestock for 75 years maybe longer than
that in research but out in the field
practicing any farmer could do AI
artificial insemination themselves and
you know with a two dollar and ninety
five cent basting syringe and a condom
to collect semen you can do it yourself
for less than five bucks
so when doctor starts telling you how
how technical this stuff is you can just
sort of smile at him and say okay doc
let's move forward here now have you
ever heard of cholesterol raise your
hand mm if you didn't raise your hand I
think you're asleep okay each year in
America we spend over a hundred billion
dollars for cholesterol testing not
treatment just cholesterol testing we
spent over 100 billion dollars a year
it's a huge industry just for
cholesterol testing that's why you know
doctors made everybody in America
paranoid how many of you had anybody in
your family lived in their 80s or 90s
raise your hand sure I think most people
in America have had somebody in their
family lived to be 80 90 I guarantee
they ate eggs they cooked in butter they
didn't have margarine back then they
salted their food these people smoked
they gosh they read meat instead of tofu
they ate eggs instead of eight beaters
they did an exercise and yet they lived
to be 80 90 men went on to live to be
100 and following their advice we're
going backwards spending a hundred
billion dollars a year for cholesterol
levels and eating away doctors have told
us most people Revere their doctors
we've gone from 17 enrolled longevity to
24th so it doesn't seem like all that's
doing much good well if any of you can
find me a disease if anybody in this
room can find me any disease that is
caused by elevated blood cholesterol
triglycerides they'll give you a million
dollars small bills and any offshore
account you want tax-free there's not a
single disease caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides when you have
elevated blood cholesterol triglycerides
I kind of look for other things you
might have a deficiency of niacin
vitamin d3
you have deficiencies of chromium
vanadium 2 trace minerals you might have
deficiencies of the essential fatty
acids or a ratio problem between Omega 3
and Omega 6s you could have early goiter
or hypothyroidism will cause an
elevation in your blood triglycerides
and blood cholesterol you can have early
diabetes you have early diabetes even
before your blood sugar goes up your
blood cholesterol triglycerides go up
when you have diabetes don't take my
word for it go to the library and look
in a medical book on diagnosis what's
the first blood changes that occur when
you have diabetes I'll get a blood close
for entry list right what's the first
blood changes when you have
low thyroid elevated blood class French
glycerides Joe the elevated blood class
drive cholesterol triglycerides cause
any disease know they're just signals or
just signals to look somewhere do they
cause cardiovascular disease no have
nothing to do with cardiovascular get so
excited about lowering your cholesterol
and lowering your blood triglycerides
because they get a kick back every time
they write a prescription for stanton
drugs lip it to our low ped and lipitor
why would you take a drug it doesn't
really do anything doesn't prevent
diseases lowers your cholesterol that's
what they do but it causes liver
cirrhosis and blindness that's why you
got to go in every couple of months to
get your blood taken and see how your
liver is doing they got a look in your
eye to make sure you're not going blind
yet why would you take a drug that gives
you liver cirrhosis and makes you go
blind when it doesn't do anything it
turns out that HRT estrogen and
progesterone combinations premarin and
and drugs like this increase the risk of
breast and uterine and ovarian cancer by
a 78 percent increase the risk of
dementia now Center disease by 200%
increase the risk of cardiovascular
disease by 200 percent and a new study
that just came out a couple of days ago
again I don't have a slide for it yet
and I apologize increases your risk of
asthma by 100 percent increases your
risk of gradual deafness as you get
older by 30% why would anybody want to
take HRT well dr. Wallach you got to get
rid of the hot flashes some way I said
well why would you risk all these
terrible things just to get rid of hot
flashes night sweats see you're just a
man you have no idea I mean women used
to beat me up all the time on my
practice go say well it's not worth it
and so we went back to the old Lydia
pink Ohm's formulas and guess what
worked like a charm
there's 29 major studies which shows it
gets rid of the hot flashes and night
sweats then you throw in the liquid
calcium and guess what 1,200 milligrams
per serving you deal with the concerns
about osteoporosis you don't have to
have all the risk from the HRT you don't
have to have all the risk from HRT
this came out actually in 2000 and they
said and they predicted that the report
on carcinogens or cancer-causing
chemicals which which was going to come
out in January 2002 is going to list
estrogen as a cancer-causing chemical
well guess what that report comes out
every year and guess what's at the top
of the list of cancer-causing chemicals
estrogen what makes it most dangerous is
doctors prescribe it doctors prescribe
it
obesity forty percent of Americans are
overweight now they're obese thirty
pounds overweight or their ideal weight
for their body type and the height and
so forth forty percent of Americans are
obese this is relatively new fifty years
ago it was like fifteen percent and a
hundred years ago there was very rarely
you know less than one percent of
Americans are obese and it turns out
it's caused by a simple single problem I
can walk on a horse form I can tell you
in 30 seconds if the horses on that farm
are getting all the minerals they need
this is a little working wagon in an
Amish farm in Lancaster County
Pennsylvania and I walked on that place
and I knew immediately that the horses
weren't getting all the minerals they
needed because the horses were eating
nibbling all along this buckboard rail
and then they just ate this one
particular place why did they eat at one
particular place because that's where
the farmer put his hand he jumped out of
the wagon every time his hot sweaty hand
full of what salt okay now my daddy had
a fourth-grade education and he knew
every time he'd see our cattle chewing
on the fence and eating dirt and chewing
on the feed box instead of eating the
feed they were mentally deficient he'd
give him minerals that go away and we
usually learned painfully when we were a
kid that's not socially acceptable to
chew on the furniture and eat dirt
Pam don't do that anymore that chair
cost a lot of money if you're that
hungry go into the kitchen and have a
piece of pie and ice cream read a
Twinkie or have a RC and a moon pie and
so people began to recognize these
cravings which we call Pike and cribbing
and animals and munchies and people the
munchies and people are Pike and
tripping and animals
Pike and cribbing and animals as
munchies in people and so we've been
taught that these cravings and the
munchies are due to a Twinkie deficiency
now if we're taught as kids as this is
caused by a mineral deficient so it all
take minerals that have zero calories in
them Americans would all be slim weight
problems are nothing more than a mineral
deficiency disease now nobody knows more
about weight weight gain weight loss and
veterinarians why is that when you put
an animal into the feet lot what are
they supposed to do lose weight or gain
weight gain weight so we know the
technology and snack food companies know
this they spend a lot of money on
research learning the technology of
weight gain and they fixed their little
snacks to make sure that you just can't
eat one fat one of them Lay's potato
chips even uses that as their motto on
their bag you just can't eat one and so
they fix it so you're mentally deficient
if you eat their stuff okay if you take
your minerals the cravings go away and
that alone you can lose 10 15 20 pounds
just because you're not desiring to eat
things between meals you're not gonna
you sit there and watch TV and fill your
face all night because you don't have
those cravings anymore it's not a
problem with your self-respect it's not
a problem you don't have a deficiency of
hypnosis you don't have a deficiency of
acupuncture you don't have a deficiency
of ephedra you have deficiencies of
minerals you take your mineral program
and eat a couple of meal replacers a day
give up some carbohydrates which you
learn from Clive McKay and and William
Banting and so forth and Bob Atkins you
give up carbohydrates and your bread and
your pastas and your rice and your
potatoes and your lose weight and keep
it off
it won't come back as long as you stay
on that program but as soon as you go
off your minerals the cravings start up
again because it's a mineral deficiency
you will always get rid of the cravings
within ten to fourteen days now I want
to talk briefly about three serious ones
we're first going to talk about cancer
some of the more serious diseases this
came out in 1997 we had spent thirty
billion dollars on a war on cancer this
bill was signed by Nixon when he was in
office
and despite 26 years of spending this
thirty billion dollars researchers
suggest putting emphasis on prevention
now you give me three or thirty billion
dollars one year's time I'll find you a
cure why couldn't they find a cure for
thirty billion dollars I mean we only
took a hundred million to fly a man to
the moon put him on the moon surface
pick him up and bring him back a hundred
million dollars to do that thirty
billion dollars they'd look for a cure
but they didn't think outside the box
they weren't really looking for a cure
they spent all the time looking for a
better chemotherapy with your tax money
because that's where the money is well
during that time every five years or so
they doubled the amount of money for
research the death rate remained the
same so they weren't looking in the
right place obviously we're really
looking that hard I know your doctors
didn't tell you about this one this one
came out in October of 1998 there's a
Harvard Nurses Health Study had 90,000
nurses
20 years of data and they could only use
15 years of the 20 years of data in the
study but these 90 thousand nurses
because for the first five years there
were not enough nurses using multiple
vitamins and what they found out was
these 90 thousand hours is to take
multiple vitamins for at least 15 years
can cut the risk of colon cancer by 75%
are there any drugs that will do that is
there a drug in the market that will cut
your risk of colon cancer by 75% no how
come your doctors didn't email you call
you up call you bring in say look here's
something really remarkable just by
taking one multivitamin every day can
you can reduce your risk of colon cancer
by 75% yahoo do they do that no I bet
not a single one of you got any direct
communication from your medical doctor
telling you this they read it in their
journals at Harvard Nurses Health Study
but they believe it or not have you ever
heard that a low-fat that will reduce
your risk
colon cancer and breast cancer and all
kinds of cancers how many heard that
would you believe it or not yeah this is
one of the American Cancer Society
doctors the American Medical Association
everybody says low fat doubtful reduce
risky cancer high fat does increase your
risk of cancer Harvard Nurses Health
Study 90,000 nurses 20 years of data
they compared the rate of cancer in
these ninety thousand nurses comparing
those that had more than 50% of their
calories as fat which is a very very
high fat diet compared to those that had
less than 20% of their calories as fat
which is very low fat diet and if fat
content of your diet had anything to do
with the rate of cancer the ones having
more than 50% of their calories as fat
should have a lot more cancer than ones
having less than 20% and that's real
simple stuff right well this came out in
March of 1999 it was published in the
journal American Medical Association
again they compared the the rate of
cancer in these 90 thousand nurses
comparing those that had less than 20%
their calories as fat versus those that
had more than 50% their calories in fat
they found no measurable difference the
amount of fat your dad has nothing to do
with the rate of cancer the amount of
failure your dad has nothing to do with
the rate of cancer nothing it turns out
the amount of fat in your diet has
nothing to do with rate of cancer is how
you cook the fat it's how you cooked the
fat not the amount of fat it's how you
cook the fat this study came out in 1998
University of South Carolina big study
study links very well-done meat to
breast cancer and then later on to
prostate cancer and colon cancer among
women who preferred all their meat very
well-done with a doneness score 9 where
the fat was burnt it tastes very good
believe me burnt fat tastes very good I
used to eat when I was a kid there was a
462 percent greater chance of having
breast cancer than for women who ate
their meat rare or medium not a 5
percent increase in risk not a 50
percent not 100 percent out of 200
percent not a 300 percent out of 400 but
a 462 percent increase in risk of
getting breast cancer colon cancer and
prostate cancer
if you eat your meat cooked well done
and eat burnt animal fat after tonight
you can't claim you were not informed if
you go home you continue to eat burnt
animal fat whether it's in hotdogs skins
over the fire you know or you're
grilling chicken skin and eating it that
way or you're grilling your hamburgers
burnt you know I get people like cringe
feel like I want my hamburger burnt I
don't see any pink in there
I want to burnt burnt I want like
charcoal they're doomed even God can't
help him you know you're that stupid God
can't help you and when you're in the
bottom in the gene pool he's got to let
you go and with you believe it or not
honey you're heard that a high-fiber
doubt will reduce your risk of colon
cancer with a believe it or not how many
heard that yeah that's another one of
those truisms that the American Cancer
Society your doctor wants you to believe
of course
Quaker Oats likes that one right low fat
diet high-fiber diet Harvard Nurses
Health Study 90,000 nurses they compared
the rate of colon cancer these ninety
thousand verses comparing those that had
a high-fiber diet versus those of low
fiber diet they didn't like the results
so they threw in fifty thousand male
doctors they compared their rate of
colon cancer the ones who had of
high-fiber dot versus those at a low
fiber type now they had one hundred and
forty thousand human subjects and this
came out in January of 1999 it was
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine very respectable Medical
Journal ninety thousand female nurses
fifty thousand male doctors they said
high fiber diets don't cut colon cancer
by any measurable amount zero nada
eating a high-fiber diet did not protect
you in any way shape or form from any
cancer Cyril why did doctors get so
excited about a high-fiber diet because
it will reduce your cholesterol that's
because it absorbs everything that you
eat including minerals that are required
to keep you from getting high blood
pressure osteoporosis arthritis cancer
and so people who eat multi grain breads
for their toast and English muffins and
pancakes and waffles for breakfast
people who eat multigrain pastas people
who eat multi grain breads and whole
wheat breads and grind their own wheat
and all that sort of stuff for their
sandwiches and people eat whole wheat
multigrain and bread for dinner
they'd whole wheat ice cream I mean it
you go to extreme right they have a 500%
increase in risk of all these other
degenerative diseases which kill you so
by eating a high-fiber diet your risk of
those other diseases goes up and doesn't
affect your risk of cancer at all the
only thing the doctors get excited about
really about a high-fiber diet that
lowers your cholesterol and does that do
anything for you no doesn't do a thing
you reduce your risk of colon cancer by
60 to 80% fighting dark berries
raspberries black raspberries
blueberries blackberries black cherries
strawberries according to the Ohio
University big study by Ohio University
reduced risk of colon cancer by 60 to 80
percent have you ever heard of trace
mineral selenium good how many heard the
trace mineral of selenium is a great
antioxidants gonna reduce your risk of
cancer whether you believe it or not I'm
here heard that okay well this has been
kind of a recent thing they're going to
grow in crazy over selenium in fact the
information on selenium really came out
in April of 1912 and this very famous
medical journal called Popular Mechanics
April of 1912 and this fella here
professor professor dr. von Wasserman
from Berlin who went on about ten years
later to get a Nobel Prize in medicine
said that he had discovered a chemical
substance that will cure cancer in mice
it turns out as the trace nor selenium
the selenium has a selective action
against cancer cells that doesn't hurt
healthy tissues dr. Wasserman believed
that the cancer mice were so similar to
those in humans that he believed in
important advance had been made towards
the Cure that veritable scourge cancer
in people well this was April of 1912 we
began to put the trace for selenium into
animal feed pellets back in April of
1912 to keep their rate of cancer down
this laid dormant for eighty-four years
in human medicine nutrition until
December of 1996 I never heard of free
radicals good how many heard trans fatty
acids yeah there's a common worse day
everybody in the street even little
six-year-old kids know about these
things and yet doctors continue to
recommend to consume free radicals and
trans fatty acids if I were to come out
with a product dr. Wallace 100% pure
free radicals the finest trans fatty
acids in the world and I'd label put him
in a health food store how many people
would buy them zero okay I wouldn't sell
any of them and yet everybody listens to
the doctors when the doctors say I want
to use margarine instead of butter
margarine is nothing more than a big
block of trans fatty acids and free
radicals it is pure 100
trans fatty acids and free radicals they
killed more Americans with margarine in
America than all the wars put together
the 200 plus years have been the country
both domestic and foreign and so if you
have any margin at home tonight I want
you to go home and box it up and ship it
UPS to Castro put a little note in there
that says my cardiologist says this is
good for your heart now you know a show
of good faith I'm sending us a margarine
hopefully I know he'll be stupid enough
to use it now I like to have my patients
eat six to ten eggs a day the more eggs
eat the lower your cholesterol goes more
eggs eat the Lorre cholesterol goes I
personally need six eggs a day so I hope
you do too they're great protein and if
you don't fry them don't fry them don't
cook them in margarine you want to poach
them soft boil them hard boil them soft
scrambled and butter at low temperature
this came out in 1995 this little study
was presented the annual meeting the
American Heart Association in Anaheim
California they said two eggs a day
won't hurt and when that report came out
in 1995 that sent a shock wave for the
entire medical system because part of
that report coming out eggs were the
father of the devil I mean if you ate
eggs you were doomed nobody would hang
around you he's an egg eater you know I
really like this one makes my 10:00 look
pretty conservative this came out 13
years ago New England Journal of
Medicine very respectable Medical
Journal normal cholesterol in an 88 year
old man who needs 25 eggs a day now you
have to ask yourself why was his old
duty in 25 eggs a day maybe he didn't
have any teeth and couldn't eat steaks
anymore maybe he owned an egg farm liked
to do his own quality control I think
was more more scientific than that he
appreciate that 95 percent 95 percent of
male sex hormone testosterone 95 percent
of female sex hormones estrogen
progesterone 95 percent of the weight of
our adrenal hormones adrenaline comes
from a master steroid in their body is
made from a master steroid in our body
called cholesterol you can only make 10
percent the other 90% must
from your diet and when your adrenal
glands are exhausted what's the most
likely thing that you're not consuming
enough of cholesterol you're sitting
there watching TV guys when your wife
saying hey look at my nice nightgown
would you rather watch TV or watch me
mmm-hmm and she's got a gaucho on an
egg-free butter free chicken skin free
red meat free diet
[Music]
yeah have you ever wondered why there's
no flourishing colony as of Aegon's I'll
sit around and hum have you heard
alzheimers disease it's a physician
cause disease mark my words aren't my
words in the next two years maybe even
next week it'll pop up in the newspaper
there's more than enough information to
prove that it's a physician cause
disease alzheimers disease is a disease
it did not occur even by another name
forty years ago only became recognized
as a disease 1979 25 years ago today
it's the number four killer of adults
over the age of 65 behind I have to
throw in Dockers now the doctors
cardiovascular disease cancer diabetes
and Alzheimer's disease
now our brains are made up of 75% a
fatty insulation material called myelin
how many heard a myelin good well myelin
is this fatty insulation material in the
brain
how do your eating of a brain sandwich
brain and egg sandwich oh you haven't
lived until you the brain sandwich it is
good a little bit of onion and mustard I
mean there's nothing better than a brain
sandwich it's real cheap now because
everybody's afraid of you know mad cow
disease so I buy more brains I eat it at
a rate this myelin makes up 75 percent
of our brain weight it's so important to
the animal in human brain myelin is 75
percent of our brain weight and myelin
is a hundred percent cholesterol you
know they make ten percent of your daily
need the other ninety percent must come
from your food if you're very very good
at listening to your doctor's
instructions does that sound familiar
September 2000 difficut
if you listen to your doctor and you
give up eggs and eat egg beaters if you
give up butter neat margarine if you rip
the chickens skin off your chicken
before you eat it you tofu instead of
red meat the odds are you're gonna get
what alzheimers disease this came out
four years ago March of 2000 Alzheimers
tidal wave is feared is coming they said
within the next 25 years 14 million
Americans are gonna dive Alzheimers e's
today 25 years backwards only 250,000
died of it and 25 years backwards from
that nobody died from
now why would you go from zero to
250,000 to 14 million well that's
because the baby boomers are coming
along and they listened to the doctors
they believed in technology and they
believed in doctors and they believed if
they followed the doctor's advice he
could be healthier and live to be 100
and so now baby boomers are the ones
that get a higher rate and higher
percentage of Alice our disease and our
older relatives who could care less okay
remember remember Ralph Charles still
flying airplanes at 100 Harold Stillson
still hitting in golf hole-in-one 101
mazuma dusty a hundred and sixty-one
still babysitting and singing lullabies
and maybe cooking and so on we
eliminated alzheimers disease in animals
65 years ago there's a human study that
came out in July of 1992 vitamin E
Candy's memory loss nails hammers
patients this is a study by the
University of California San Diego
Medical School and the Salk Institute
infamous for the sock polio vaccine they
said that vitamin E could bring back a
certain amount of memory and make people
functional again well nobody could
believe that was true so they redid the
study and five years later they came out
with this vitamin E might slow
al-harazi's
high-dose is a common vitamin E and slow
the devastating climb for some
Alessandra's patients significantly
delaying the need for nursing home care
again the University of California San
Diego University Medical School now if
you can delay the need for nursing home
care for a spouse or a child or a parent
grandparent aunt uncle as Allison I'm
diseased by five years would that be
emotionally and financially beneficial
to a family of course it would
why don't doctors tell you this well
because they own the stock of the
nursing home in your town that takes
care of Alexandra's patients they don't
want this to get out this came out in
2003 November 2003 a study by Tufts
University Medical School in Boston they
found out you could reduce your risk of
Alzheimer disease by 48 percent by just
taking either supplements or fish three
times a day to get the omega-3 essential
fatty acids this has been repeated over
and over and over
this just came out January 2004
people taking vitamin C anywhere 78%
lice less likely to have a diagnosis
Valentine disease now didn't even think
about the diet getting rid of fried
foods and margins and sources of free
radicals they didn't even think about
eating cholesterol this was just some
antioxidants and so we know from animal
studies and these sort of early studies
and human beings that if you eat enough
cholesterol not fried not cooked in
margarine but poached and soft-boiled
and hard-boiled and soft scrambling
butter and meat medium rare and so forth
which we'll talk about in a minute and
take in antioxidants the odds of you
getting Alzheimer's disease reduced
almost zero I have to go ask my doctor
he's only going to be 56 why would you
ask him how do you ever heard of high
blood pressure raise your hand
sure everybody knows about high blood
pressure very common disease how many
ever heard of a veterinarian telling you
need to give your dog a calcium channel
blocker a beta blocker for high blood
pressure
not very often how about your goldfish
what about your parakeet and guinea pigs
you know every animal can get high blood
pressure just like people reason why
they don't is in these little pellets we
talked about earlier we put things in
there so they don't get it they can get
it but they don't get it because they
put the stuff in the pellets so they
don't get it how do you heard that salt
is bad for it when it comes to blood
pressure salts gonna initiate high blood
pressure how much have you ever heard
that genetics has something to do with
it well both of those are wrong salt has
nothing to do with high blood pressure
and gen-x has nothing to with high blood
pressure it's a simple deficiency of a
single nutrient a single deficiency of a
single nutrient we've eliminated high
blood pressure in all these animals
what's the first thing a good farmer
puts out for his livestock in the
pasture salt block or salt lake isn't it
there's nobody out in the pasture tone
of cow he's limited to one lick a day is
her
and I refuse to believe my human
patients are dumber than a cow or a
sheep say look go ahead and saw your
food to taste don't worry about it if
you put too much salt on there it won't
taste good you won't eat it remember the
Japanese they consume an entire salt
shaker per person a day 15 grams of salt
today and they have 85% less
cardiovascular disease and we do and how
about pressures not even in their
vocabulary because they don't get it
very often well this came out in July of
1997 they redeemed in my view on redeem
my view on salt says doctors lack proof
that too much salt is unhelpful after
years of telling healthy people that too
much salt isn't good for them
researchers still don't have solid
evidence to back up that claim now what
did doctors call people who give an
unsubstantiated health and medical
advice for a profit
calm quacks don't they next time you
have a doctor says look I need you to
give up salt because we're getting to
that age we got to worry about your
blood pressure hey doc you're a quack
there's no evidence to support that
claim yeah I know you want to give me
those statin drugs and blood pressure
medication even though I don't have
those problems and you need to go back
and kind of read your stuff here because
that's not true well there was a
wonderful study done by the US
government called the sodium task force
once and for all they were trying to
prove that salt was the cause of high
blood pressure
this was potion April of 1997 and this
is the bottom line of the study was
called the sodium task force 1997 you
can look it up on the Internet the study
found that people who limited their salt
intake to a thousand milligrams or one
gram a day like doctors want you to do
have six times more heart attack six
hundred percent more heart attacks than
those who defy their doctors and eight
double that amount if you listen to your
doctor you had six times more heart
attacks than people who defy their
doctors and eight double that amount
so what mineral are we talking about
what mineral are we talking about when
it comes to high blood pressure it turns
out it's a deficiency of calcium you can
drink 50 gallons of milk a day and you
can't get enough calcium to get your
blood pressure down you need 25 pounds
of cheese a day and the only thing will
happen is it'll be so constipated you'll
need a jackhammer to have a bowel
movement if you didn't have hemorrhoids
you're going to get them you can take
all the tums you want you can take all
the oyster shell egg shell lime storm
coral calcium you want nothing's gonna
happen that's because you take a
thousand milligrams of limestone or
calcium carbonate which is coral calcium
and eggshell an oyster shell all those
are the same chemical formula you take a
thousand milligrams camp so you're not
getting a thousand milligrams of calcium
only a hundred and forty milligrams is
elemental calcium 860 milligrams is
carbonate and because it's an elemental
form of calcium because it's an
elemental form of calcium you only get
10% so 10% of 140 milligrams is 14 if
you take two of those 1,000 milligram
capsules of calcium carbonate in any way
shape or form you get 28 milligrams of
calcium it's not going to do you much
good but it comes to arthritis
osteoporosis high blood pressure
periodontal disease etc etc we've
eliminated a lot of high blood pressure
at animals and some very famous people
who didn't want to use drugs how many
ever heard of menopause raise your hand
say not even the guys are raising their
hand well up until about 1958 every
doctor used to make 50 cents on
dispensing a little herbal formula
called Lydia Pinkham somebody heard of
Lydia pink oh yeah lady pink is very
famous herbal formula and we get rid of
the hot flashes the night sweats but
doctors only made 50 cents when they
dispensed a bottle in 1958
pharmaceutical companies came out with
HRT hormone replacement therapy and all
the research was done by veterinarians
and they were told not to give it to
humans because it did terrible things to
laboratory animals as well that may be
true in laboratory
but it hasn't been proven to humans yet
we're gonna have to kill a lot of women
with this stuff before we get you know
too excited about taking off the market
and so they began to encourage women to
take HRT in 1958 when there are cures
available so they're not going to use
the nutritional import reproach they're
not going to use the nutritional
approach they're going to use
arthroscopic surgery the knee because as
it worth 1.5 billion dollars to them and
so you have to be smart enough your
doctor says look you've got bone to bone
arthritis of your knee in the old days
we'd have to go right to the joint
replacement surgery but right now we've
got arthroscopic surgery than even we
can take out those little floating bits
of bone and cartilage and then and that
doesn't work anymore we'll eventually
have to go to the current placement
surgery but right now we might be able
to preserve your knee for a year or two
you have to be strong enough to say look
doc you're a quack how many people did
you kill last month Journal the New
England Journal of Medicine the New
England Journal of Medicine July 2002
said this procedure is worthless now
we've been friends for a long time we
belong to the same church and you're
coming to me with a worthless procedure
I don't think I'm going to visit you
anymore
you have to rebuild some time they keep
taking advantage you to milk your
insurance policy and milk your wallet
when do you rebuild your repeal when you
realize that your doctor is only looking
at you as a source of income if you
follow your doctor's advice when you
have osteoporosis in arthritis are gonna
wind up like this yeah now they believe
it or not where they believe it or not
how many you ever heard that
osteoporosis is primarily a
postmenopausal woman's problem with you
believe it now
have you heard that sure everybody knows
Oprah your doctor the government
everybody knows that osteoporosis is
primarily a postmenopausal woman's
problem well we knew a hundred years ago
that osteoporosis actually occurred
equally in both men and women it only
became a postmenopausal woman's problem
in 1958 when they came out with HRT
because can you justify treating
osteoporosis and preventing osteoporosis
with estrogen at both men and women get
it at the same rate no you couldn't you
imagined a red-blooded American man a
red-blooded
Idahoan going to the doctor's okay doc
I've got that osteoporosis stuff I want
you to shoot me up with that estrogen
I've had estrogen today they're not
gonna do it you're just not gonna do it
people tend to be basically smart right
well this came out in November of 2001
osteoporosis strikes both sexes equally
Manners likely as women is suffering
from osteoporosis the surprise findings
but why was this a surprise finding will
cause all the doctors who did that study
only graduated after the 1958 time
period and the truth they were taught
was that osteoporosis occurs primarily
in postmenopausal women results turn the
tables on the belief that women are the
prime victims of condition the findings
of the Canadian multicenter osteoporosis
study a program involving almost 10,000
participants in nine centers well and
will certainly change the way that
medical professionals deal with
unexplained bone fractures and men in
the way education about the condition is
handled a raise your hand gentlemen if
you have received a direct communication
from your medical doctor either an email
a postcard a phone call saying look come
on in I've just learned that
osteoporosis occurs equally in both men
and women I'm so excited about this
because I can help you before something
bad happens come on in we'll do a bone
density test how many of you men I've
gotten that communication for your
medical doctors look at that none as I
traveled around the world 18 countries
in the last three years a single man has
raised their hand okay well why would
that be why wouldn't doctors want to
tell their men patients you'd think
they'd be excited throughout ruining
their out there to help you they'd be
wanting to give you this information
right well guess what would happen every
woman would immediately stop using HRT
and they're making so much money from
the kickbacks and write the
prescriptions from HRT they're afraid to
rock the boat
they don't want to start anything that's
going to rock the boat so any doctor who
today continues to write prescriptions
for women for HRT should be put in jail
for 25 years of life without possibility
of parole and that would be the kindest
of treatments that I would figure it for
them
ladies when your doctor comes to you and
says I want you to take estrogen and ask
your ferocity Prosis you say doc you
take it for 25 years and then if it
works I'll take it let's see what he
says
one of the other things you have to do
besides taking all the raw materials to
rebuild your bone and cartilage and
ligaments and tendons connective tissue
is to give up carbonated drinks
carbonated drinks are the single
greatest contributor to osteoporosis and
arthritis and fractures of the bone they
interfere with the absorption of
nutrients especially minerals digesting
protein this actually the original study
was done ten years before this at the
Harvard Nurses Health Study ninety
thousand nurses 20 years of data and
these were all nurses over aged 35 they
found out that the nurses drinking
carbonated drinks soft drinks even diet
drinks instead of water during the day
had a 500% increase in risk of
osteoporosis and fractures over the
water drinking group so they went and
did the study in junior high school
girls 460 junior high school girls in
ninth and tenth grade they found out
that the same thing was exactly true for
them why did they only look at nurses
and girls because they believe it is
primarily a woman's disease but believe
me it occurs in boys too so if you have
young athletes whether they're girls or
boys if you have osteoporosis in your
family or arthritis if you have it or
don't want to get it you got to give up
carbonated drinks doctors should be
telling you this every time you walk in
the door you got to give up carbonated
drinks I'll answer questions in just a
moment I just want to remind you that if
you don't take care of your own destiny
if you don't take hold of things and and
take control of your own destiny life is
gonna take care of your destiny for you
and usually it's not very nice and so if
you take control and rebell a little bit
be one of those mean feisty little
people that defy their doctor but you
have to do it with education you just
can't just can't do something bad you
have to know what you're doing
educate yourself and the odds are you're
gonna save yourselves an enormous amount
of unnecessary misery you're gonna save
yourselves a gob of money and you're
gonna add many many many healthful years
your life it will definitely help you to
educate yourself education is power
education with action is super power
don't let somebody else even a doctor
determine your future you've got to make
those determinations yourself
information and statements regarding
dietary supplements discussed have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration and are not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease
this next one I identified with because
I grew up in a little cattle farm in
Missouri we raised purebred Angus cattle
we also had a little theater operation
to keep a kind of an even cash flow and
so I identified with this guy he was a
cattle farmer from a little town outside
of Kathmandu Nepal in the Himalayan
mountains and according to his obituary
never saw a doctor never set foot in a
hospital he smoked two packs of
cigarettes a day for 120 years he wasn't
a vegetarian raising cattle he ate red
meat every day and in April of 1998 he
died at age 141 when he was a young man
he led the first land survey team around
Kathmandu in 1888 the last one is share
with you tells a lot of stories is one
of my favorite obituaries it's about an
Iranian woman by the name of mazuma
dusty and this was published in the
Rocky Mountain News wire service out of
Denver Colorado in January from 1995
it said mazuma dusty died aged 161 now
this seems pretty outrageous but you
have to give a lot of credibility of
this obituaries she was survived by six
living children ranging in age from 120
228 they hadn't even left home to go to
college yet I thought this was a very
profound observation by her oldest son
Gollum her oldest son said his mother
had never visited a doctor never taken
any prescription medications or
over-the-counter medications you only
use herbs or in life now do you think
she had access to vaccinations when she
was a child any of her kids get Backson
aidid now their barn up in a Little Rock
Hut up in the mountains of a village
Calton Bala in Khorasan province in Iran
okay and I guarantee issue is functional
until very close to her death because
they don't have nursing homes and
they're not just gonna find some way to
give her IVs to keep her alive they're
in that rock Hut and so she had to be a
still able to snap beans and skinned
carrots and cook and sing lullabies the
great-great great-great grandkids and
whatever she did she did and sewed maybe
we all have these genetic capacity to
live well beyond a hundred experts in
longevity experts in gerontology and
genetics tell us we all every one of us
everyone in this room has the ability to
live well beyond 100 and the only reason
why we don't the shortest way to say it
is because we do too much of the bad
stuff and not enough of the good stuff
that's the most extinct way I can say it
we all have the genetic capability to do
it one of the fascinating things to me
is that we asked doctors about what to
do for health and longevity
now if doctors knew what they were
talking about that would make sense
and I'm a scorecard kind of guy and so
I'm looking at doctors and saying really
do they really really know what they're
talking about
well my tape dead doctors don't lie
which came out in 1994 I had a statistic
in there from a small survey it said
doctors lived to be 57 point six and I
rounded up to 58 to give them the
benefit the doubt and doctors just went
ballistic well well like you got to be
lying we don't live to be 58 we live to
be 75 like everybody else well even if
they live to be 75 like everybody else
that wouldn't be too good a
recommendation because if they're the
holders of all knowledge and health and
they follow their own recommendations
they should live to be 85 or 95 or
hundred or something well they didn't
want to believe me so they did their own
study and they came out 5 years later in
1999 with the answer to their study and
they found out that doctors in America
live to be 56 so I missed it by two
years so why do we ask people how to
live a long healthy life who only live
to be 56 on the average that's because
they have convinced us that health care
is very very not only important but also
very detailed it's very complicated
and you have to go to school for 14
years to know how to deal with health
care and they've convinced Americans as
this is true I mean you can't pick up a
newspaper or watch TV or listen to the
radio without health care and Medicare
and Medicaid and all this stuff being on
the front right well let's look at some
more score cars and see if we're getting
the bang for a buck right now in tire
world each year spends 2.7 trillion
dollars for health care 2.7 trillion
with a T out of that 2.7 trillion
dollars each year that the world spends
for health care the US alone alone the
u.s. spends 1.6 trillion more than half
and yet in April of 1990 we ranked 17th
and longevity
there were 16 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we did we need
him in rank in the top 10 you have to
ask well who is number 1 what did they
do different from us well the Japanese
were number 1 they live to be seventy
nine point one four point one years
longer than we did and the interesting
thing was the Japanese are heavy smokers
68 percent of the Japanese smoke three
to five packs of cigarettes a day they
are heavy smokers they are the smokiness
nation on earth and yet they have
eighty-five percent less cancer and
cardiovascular disease and we do
Japanese consume 12 to 15 grams of salt
every day an entire salt shaker per
person we're supposed to consume
approximately one gram 1000 milligrams a
day of salt and yet they have 85% less
cardiovascular disease and we do we
dropped two atomic bombs on the Japanese
in World War two they've had more
radiation per person than any other
culture on earth nobody cleaned it up
they've been wallowing in all the
radiation in the soil and water in
environment ever since we dropped the
bombs on nobody cleaned it up and they
have 85 percent less cancer than we do
and so I want to know what they know in
all this adversity they're still living
longer than us and are healthier than us
he said well maybe that was a bad study
it should be redone well they did 10
years later June of 2000 they reran the
same study and the Japanese maintained
number one but they dropped from seventy
nine point one down to 74 point five so
this is our chance to catch up and
surpass them with all this money we're
spending but instead we drop from 17 s
longevity all the way down to 24th as we
went from 75 to 73 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do now you
don't have to be a genius to figure out
we're not getting the bang for the buck
you don't have to be a genius to say
well maybe the medications we're getting
aren't doing a good maybe the advice
we're getting is not the best no matter
what the doctors tell us we're going the
wrong direction so you can't deny these
facts okay can't deny the facts
well there's 250,000 drugs
pharmaceuticals in the PDR the
physicians Desk Reference that they have
access to to treat people in America
there's new ones coming out all the time
they're always bragging about how many
billions of dollars worth of research
they spend every year to find new drugs
and if you take out the 500 antibiotics
as still leaves 240 9500 drugs there's
not a single one of those design
cure anything there's not a single drug
and the PD arts that maybe antibiotics
might cure a strep throat other than
that there's not a single drug in the
PDR that cures anything they're all
designed in milk your insurance policies
their own designed to milk Medicare and
Medicaid they're all designed to milk
your your wallet because there's no laws
requiring the pharmaceutical companies
to manufacture drugs at your even though
they could but because there's no laws
requiring them to do it they don't this
just came out in January of this year
health spending has biggest surge in 11
years we're doing a jump right over here
say you'ii Rinehart a health economists
at Princeton said the increase in
healthcare spending is no surprise this
is what the American people asked for
when they abolished managed care what he
said there was this for about eight
years the cost of health care stayed the
same when there was managed care doctors
didn't like it because managed care kept
them from doing unnecessary tests
managing health care kept them from
doing unnecessary surgeries writing
prescriptions for unnecessary drugs and
they didn't like it because it cut their
income in half they weren't getting the
kickbacks anymore and so they began to
whisper to their patients you know
there's a economist there is a
bookkeeper making decisions what tests
you should have and what drugs you
should get and what treatment should say
it should be my job I'm a doctor should
be my job and after a while people said
yeah it should be the doctors job why is
some book keeper doing that and so they
convinced the American public the the
managed care was no good and so people
then complain to their legislatures were
then voted it out and of course their
workplaces went to other things other
than managed care and immediately what
managed care got dumped health care
double and tripled and it's just going
up like a skyrocket because now there's
no controls on the doctors
well how does this affect us this came
out in May of 2003 age 65 plus workforce
rose sharply since 1980 Americans are
living longer and they're fretting about
their financial security what is the
biggest reason why people are worried
about their financial security health
care health care right health care is
the biggest thing that people worry
about as you get older you need more
health care and there's all kinds of
things happening because of health care
doctors always get paid you're gonna pay
it your employer is gonna pay it the
government's gonna pay it they don't
worry they're happy right I thought this
is a really a very interesting editorial
this came out in February of this year
just last month just about a month ago
outsourcing the American dream how many
of you heard of outsourcing okay good
that's half if you're outsourcing means
that they're sending American jobs to
other countries I'll give you an example
these big corporations are training
Indian people in New Delhi how to speak
with a Texas accent so when you call up
you know you see something on TV you
want to order or you know catalog it
says call this toll-free number or you
may want to make an appointment for a
appliance repairman to come out of your
house and put a new motor in your and
your dryer or something when you call it
they say howdy ma'am how y'all doing
because they've taught these guys in
Pakistan and India how to speak with a
Texas accent how can we hip you and only
rings three times and they pick it up a
New Delhi India and they take this ardor
hmm well what they said was this by the
time 2006 comes between 35 and 45
percent of current full-time IT jobs
which are these information technology
jobs will be sent overseas this amounts
to fourteen million jobs fourteen
million jobs in the next year and a half
or going overseas and here's why
while telephone operators in the United
States are in an average of $12.50 an
hour plus their healthcare benefits in
India they earn less than a dollar and
no healthcare benefits and because of
NAFTA how many heard of NAFTA the NAFTA
agreement with all these countries gave
our government permission to give
corporation
tax benefits to send the jobs out of the
country we give tax benefits to
companies to send jobs out of the
country now how absurd is that that is
really absurd
it's absolutely criminal right that says
payroll clerks an Asian nation take home
less than $2 an hour and no health
benefits and their counterparts in this
country averages 15 dollars and 17 cents
an hour with health benefits so is
health benefits climb and companies
don't want to pay them anymore they
start outsourcing the jobs to countries
that don't have health benefits and what
happens to the people who are here left
in the United States well they still
have to pay for their health care this
came out in June of 2003 study finds
doctors skipped key steps of treatments
doctors failed to take about half the
recommended steps for treating common
illnesses such as high blood pressure
and diabetes suggesting that health care
in the United States isn't nearly as
good as many people thought well that's
not a new belief right this came out in
October of 1999 doctors say they'd lie
to get insurers to pay this is a study
done in eight cities 169 internist they
presented this to the annual meeting the
American Association met American
Medical Association conference annual
conference in Los Angeles in October of
1999 I'm just gonna go over to them this
is actually quite a thick report I'll go
over two of them and said fifty-eight
percent supported lying so severely ill
55 year old you get a coronary bypass
even though her pains are not becoming
more frequent as they ensure required
during the managed care days now if your
pains are not becoming more frequent and
the the degree of pain remains the same
this is called stable angina and how
many of you heard of nitroglycerin yeah
for 30 50 Cent's treatment you can put a
nitro tab under your tablet may cost you
six to ten bucks a month to deal with
the pain and as long as the frequencies
the same the pain levels the same you
can do that forever and also how many of
you heard of dean ornish well dean
ornish was an md PhD from Harvard
Medical School he did a great
double-blind study where he took
hundreds of people with 85% 90% blockage
or their three main coronary arteries
and he put him on a restricted diet
gave him some supplements gave him
low-impact exercise like yoga and
swimming and in six months time all
their arteries were open 100% without
surgery this was impossible according to
surgeons the only way to deal with
blocked arteries in the heart is to do a
bypass right there's no way you can do
that with diet and exercise and
supplements and so they made him do it
again another double-blind study work
results exactly the same well what a
doctor should say today when somebody
comes to them with angina stable angina
say look let's get on a Dean Ornish
program it's actually gonna cut your
food bill in half save a little money
here we're gonna get you on a little
nutritional program supplement program
to do some yoga you can do that for free
at home here's a $10 taping and learn
how to do these yoga exercises you come
back in six months and if you're improve
we'll just keep doing the same thing if
it gets worse and we will consider the
surgery but there's no doctors who do
that
doctors kind of lie a little bit but
they want you well worse than that they
want God to believe that they're lying
on behalf of Mable or Ruth or Roy says
Lord you know I'm lying but it's not
because of me I'm lying because the mean
old managed care insurance companies
won't won't let Roy have a triple bypass
and Roy needs a triple bypass so forgive
me Lord because I have to lie for Roy
now why is that dr. Lyon is here i lying
for Roy's behalf no he's lying for his
own behalf he wants to $85,000 keep that
cash flow going when a study came out it
was a seven-year study done by dr. Larry
Clark an MD PhD from the University of
Arizona School of Medicine he took half
of a group of thirteen hundred people
gave him two hundred micrograms over
seven years two hundred micrograms of
this trace mineral selenium every day
for seven years and to make a long story
short at the end of the study his final
analysis showed that he slashed the
occurrence not the risk but the actual
occurrence of prostate cancer by 69%
are there any drugs that will do that
well doing a prostate exam and taking
your PSA your prostate specific antigen
blood test every year will that prevent
prostate cancer by 69% no he reduced the
actual occurrence of colorectal cancer
by 64% you reduce it by 75% by taking a
multivitamin reduce the actual
occurrence of lung cancer by 39 percent
with you smoked or not about 90 percent
90 percent of lung cancer occurs in
people who never smoked
smoking is not the cause of lung cancer
its inhaling all the fumes when your fry
food is a big a single cause of lung
cancer all those free radicals coming
out of that margin you're frying with
how could Ruth get lung cancer she was a
good church-going lady never cussed
never even hung around smokers how does
she get lung cancer but she was there
early every noon after church frying
food for everybody hmm oh the best part
of the story is two months after this
result came out doctor Larry Clark died
old prostate cancer at age 52 now why
did that happen
well because he had set this study up to
show that selenium didn't work he hated
selenium he set the study up to prove
that wouldn't work and he wouldn't take
it and the sick part about this is his
professor of medicine at the Medical
School of the University of Arizona so
he taught his beliefs all the medical
students there and when he died a
prostate cancer they all said aw what a
tragedy and went on avoiding selenium
now tell her patients not to take
selenium this came out March 6 2002
study says a diet rich in tomatoes can
cut the risk of prostate cancer raw
Tomatoes by 24 to 36 percent if he eat
it
tomatoes cooked one serving a day of
cooked tomato reduce your risk of
prostate cancer by 52 to 60 percent
because that antioxidant in Tomatoes
called lycopenes lycopenes I love this
when it came out in September of 1998
called green tea the cure-all of Carol's
why is that important why do we have 85
percent more cancer than the Japanese
well our national drink is coca-cola
their national drink is green tea and in
green tea contains an antioxidant
catechins or EGC jeez there are a
hundred times more potent than vitamin C
and neutralizing free radicals catechins
and EGC G's in green tea are a hundred
times more potent than vitamin C and
neutralizing free radicals
and perhaps a hundred times more potent
than vitamin C and reducing your risk of
cancer diabetes an epidemic disease in
United States there's a million new
cases a million new cases of diabetes
every year there's 32 million diabetics
as we speak right now in America 30
million of the 32 million diabetics are
antal onset type 2 diabetics that make
up the bulk of the diabetic population
and adil onset type 2 diabetics make
more insulin than non-diabetics there's
not an insulin problem with them and
usually if you're asking about insulin
say well I've got insulin how can I be a
diabetic and so doctors say well you've
got insulin resistant diabetes it's not
working the reason why it's not working
is you're deficient - trace minerals
chromium vanadium and their cofactors
necessary for them to work which are
required by your insulin to work in your
body you make tons of insulin but if you
don't have those trace minerals your
insulin is not going to work we learned
in 1957 that we could prevent and cure
antal onset type 2 diabetes and
laboratory animals pet animals and farm
animals by giving them these - trace
minerals and/or cofactors just lay
dormant for 20 years in human medicine
until 1977 when they found out that they
could give intravenous intravenous
chromium vanadium and their cofactors to
people who had diabetes and they were
unconscious from head head injuries
they're in a coma and they were
miraculously cured by giving them
intravenously these trace minerals
and/or cofactors now you can't say that
all they just believed that they were
going to get cured because they're gonna
get cured cuz they're in a coma they
know what was going on now how come your
doctor doesn't tell you this stuff it's
been proven over and over and over an
animal been proven over and over and
over people it's been published in every
big medical journal in America in the
world it sort of comes through every
couple years as renewed you know people
look at it it's not like it's a mystery
every doctor knows this
why don't doctors tell you this well if
a doctor took the less than two minutes
that I just shared with you this
information
he might get eighty dollars for a long
visit an extended visit instead of fifty
bucks for a standard visit make an extra
$30 according to the GAO of the General
Accounting Office which is the budget
watchdog
the US Congress your doctor makes over
the 25 to 40 years of diabetic lives
after diagnosis your doctor makes seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
every diabetic patient so why would he
take 30 bucks when he can make seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
most people say well my doctor belongs
my church I gotta believe in him well
don't let that protect you even members
of the Mafia go to church right so I
wouldn't bet on that one according to
the US Department of Agriculture a
hundred years ago Americans were eating
a half a pound of sugar per person per
year a half a pound of sugar per person
per year today 100 years later according
to US Department of Agriculture
Americans are eating 157 pounds of sugar
per person per year are now we're eating
a half a pound today so in a hundred
years we've gone from a half a pound of
sugar per person per year to a half a
pound of sugar per person per day that
plus the deficiency of these nutrients
in our food has resulted in this
epidemic of diabetes do you think our
genetics has changed that much I don't
think so
you look in the book rare-earths have
been cures one of our books the guy
who's doing all this study on these two
trace minerals back in the 1950s
actually dr. Walter Murch went back into
the 1940s and began to look at chromium
levels in American blood and he found
out there was a big range in 1948
micrograms per liter of parts per
billion 28 to a thousand in 1971 it
dropped a 13 in 72 it dropped to 10 and
70 through our chromium levels in her
blood dropped to four point seven to
five point one and seventy-four dropped
to zero point seven three to one point
six in 78 it dropped to zero point one
six is it going up or down it's dropping
like a rock well in 1980 it went up
three times over 1978 values to zero
point four three why did that happen
remember 1972 7 they're publishing all
these papers on how chromium vanadium
was good for you and so everybody was
taking chromium vanadium they run into
health food store hasn't taken it and so
everybody's blood levels of chromium
vanadium went up but because they
couldn't cure diabetes with chromium
vanadium without all those other
cofactors in 1985 went back down
0.13 because people got frustrated cuz
it wouldn't work if you just use those
to trace minerals without the other
cofactors so between not having enough
of these nutrients the chromium vanadium
their cofactors no food anymore and
eating all this sugar more sugar less
chromium vanadium we have a epidemic we
have an epidemic of adult onset type 2
diabetes the last one we're going to
talk about is arthritis osteoporosis
arthritis osteoporosis according to the
Center for Disease Control eighty-five
percent of all Americans over the age of
50 already have arthritis osteoporosis
of one time or another or to one degree
or another there's not a single medical
treatment designed to prevent or fix it
aspirin celebrex Vioxx talon whole
ibuprofen advil Aleve methotrexate
gulches prednisone cortisone none of
those prevent or cure osteoporosis and
arthritis they all have terrible side
effects many of which are
life-threatening and what makes this
really really really bad ladies and
gentlemen we learned how to prevent and
cure osteoporosis and arthritis and
animals over 300 years ago now we didn't
all the biochemical reasons why these
approaches worked but we knew in the
last 75 years two biochemical reasons
why these little nutritional formulas
worked but we knew how to prevent and
cure osteoporosis and arthritis and
animals for over three hundred years in
some societies a thousand years and your
doctor is still trying to just give you
painkillers and doing surgery how many
you heard of arthroscopic surgery of the
knee for our thright us that's a very
common procedure now this came out in
July of 2002 arthroscopic knee surgery
for arthritis is a worthless procedure
this is published in the New England
Journal of Medicine how many of you know
somebody who's had arthroscopic surgery
of the knee yeah well if you have
arthroscopic surgery the knee for
arthritis that doesn't deal with the
systemic problem that's going on right
just one little knee and of course
doctors in 2001 and there's only like
maybe 5,000 doctors are the 1 million
doctors who do this procedure their
income for that one procedure in 2001
was 1.5 billion dollars
now do you think they'll ever give up
that procedure no it's been proven to be
worthless published in the New England
Journal of Medicine as a worthless
procedure dr. Wallach is an expert on
nutrition in longevity and is the famed
author of the audio message dead doctors
don't lie which has been heard by more
than 50 million people get ready to
learn into laughs as dr. Wallach shares
some important facts that could very
well save your life and now here is dr.
Joel Wallach who as most of you heard
the tape dead doctors don't lie I don't
have to give a lot of introduction of
myself other than to remind you the
thing that makes my view different on
health I think is that I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician and
in veterinary medicine we don't have
health insurance for animals like we do
people and if we were to use a human
healthcare type of system for animals or
livestock the sticker shock for your
hamburger would cost you 275 dollars a
pound boneless skinless chicken breast
would be four hundred and fifty dollars
a pound a dozen eggs would be 50 bucks
just to pay for the health care so we
learned a long time ago in the animal
industry that we could keep the price of
animal products such as meat and dairy
and poultry and eggs down where the
average American could afford to eat
them every day
simply by eliminating health care cost
we do this in animals with simple little
nutritional formulas and that's why we
have mouse pellets and rat pellets and
hamster pellets and gerbil pellets and
guinea pig pellets and rabbit pellets we
have canned and dried dog and cat food
we have pig pellets and sheep pellets
and horse pellets and calf pellets and
dairy pellets and ferret pellets and
duck pellets and turkey pellets and
trout fellows and catfish pellets and
monkey pellets and a pigeon pellets in
every kind of animal you can think of
that's been domesticated or used as a
pet or laboratory animal we have pellets
for and the reason why we put animal
feeds or animal rations into a
pelletized farm is so that every
mouthful is perfect even the stupidest
animal in the group gets perfect diet
they can't sort through and just eat
only the sunflower seeds or the raisins
every mouthful is perfect we do that to
standardize production and it's been a
real blessing for the agricultural
industry we were so successful that over
the last 75 years we were able to
eliminate 900 different diseases we've
doubled and tripled lifespans of animals
with these simple little nutritional
farmers and as a veterinarian it always
it was kind of interesting to me that
that we didn't use that same technology
for people we only spent
hundred billion dollars of figuring all
this out for animals over a 75 year
period which is nothing as you will see
tonight compared to what we spend for
human health on a yearly basis so as a
pittance to eliminate 900 different
diseases and animals well one of the
things before I became a physician I was
involved with a big research project
with Marlin Perkins from the old Mutual
of Omaha Wild Kingdom show how many
remember Marlin program great gentlemen
and I was really really honored that he
would think of me as a wildlife
pathologist I was in Africa actually
doing conservation work and he sent me a
telegram invited me back to the States
in the mid-60s because he had gotten a
seven and a half million dollar grant
from the National Institutes of Health
and this was to study pollution in the
environment and the world ecology and my
job on the project was to do autopsies
of animals who died of natural causes in
the big zoos around the United States
because big zoos tended to be associated
with big cities and if there was any
pollution problems going on in the city
there was bound to be an animal in the
zoo population that would be sensitive
to the pollution we could use that
animal much like the old coal miners
used to use Canaries and they take the
canary down the mine and if a little gas
or methane would would leak into the
mind the Canaries were much more
sensitive than the men and they would
drop off the perch and die long before
the men were in danger of blowing up or
suffocating so that was the purpose of
the study well make a long story short
over some years I had done 17,500
autopsies on over 450 four species of
animals and 3,000 human beings for
comparison what I learned ladies and
gentlemen was that every animal and
every human being that dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional deficiency
disease I'm gonna repeat that because
that's a great profound observation
every animal and every human being the
dies of natural causes
dies of a nutritional deficiency disease
and of course that was poo pooed by many
medical experts back then because how
could anybody die have a nutritional
disease in America right there's no
evidence to support the claim that we
can prevent and cure diseases with
vitamins minerals raise your hand have
you ever heard some version of that no
evidence to support the claiming prevent
and cure diseases with vitamins and
minerals doctors say that experts say
that professors said bureaucrats say
that everybody says that
well how many ever heard of scurvy raise
your hand
sure you know you can prevent and cure
scurvy with vitamin C how do you heard
of rickets raise your hand you know you
can prevent and cure rickets with
vitamin D kind of you heard of guider
raise your hand you know you can prevent
and cure goiter with iodine and copper
and selenium
how many be heard of anemia raise your
hand golly gee you know you can prevent
and cure anemia with iron and copper and
folic acid and vitamin b12 and what
about things like Barry Barry with
congestive heart failure you know you
can prevent and cure that with thiamine
or vitamin b1 and what about pellagra
with all the emotional stuff in
schizophrenia and diarrhea and all the
skin diseases that go along with play
grow you can prevent and cure that with
vitamin b3 or niacin and all the
essential nutrients all the essential
nutrients are called essential nutrients
because if you don't have enough you get
diseases if you get the disease you take
the nutrient goes away so any doctor any
expert any bureaucrat any professor
anybody who says there's no evidence to
support the claiming prevent and cure
diseases with with vitamins minerals as
a fool and you don't want to have a fool
for a doctor that's the last person you
want to have as a fool as a doctor right
well I was really pleased to see this
come out in October of 2002 this was a
World Health Organization study they
said that study finds life expectancy
closely mirrors dietary factors they
went on to say nearly 1/3 early death
and disability stems from nutritional or
dietary causes including too little food
in the poorest countries the wrong kind
of food in the richest countries and
then this was perhaps the most profound
observation they made inadequate intake
of three key micronutrients zinc iron
and vitamin A is responsible for an
unexpectedly high burden of disease
now there's 90 essential nutrients they
didn't even look at the other 87 okay
and so finally finally 40 years later
they came to the same conclusion so I
feel pretty good about that well as I
said there's all these essential
nutrients there's two reasons why
they're called essential nutrients
number one our bodies cannot manufacture
them we must consume them every day
either as food or supplements number two
if you're missing them you get some
horrible collection of diseases many of
which are life-threatening
that's why they're called essential
nutrients the ones I like to talk about
our mineral deficiencies because they
make up too
the essential nutrients two-thirds of
the essential nutrients from minerals
and our foods cannot manufacture them
our food plants cannot manufacture
minerals our food plants our grains
vegetables fruits and nuts can in fact
manufacture vitamins and amino acids and
fatty acids we all know that but if you
can find me any plant that'll
manufacture a mineral I'll give you a
million dollars tax-free small bills in
any offshore account you want okay
you'll be really very wealthy if you can
find me a plant they'll manufacture
minerals there's no such plan
nutritional minerals nutritional
minerals do not occur they do not occur
in a uniform blank around the crust of
the earth nutritional minerals occur in
veins like chocolate and chocolate ice
cream
nutritional minerals occur in veins like
gold and silver and the odds of you
getting all essential nutrients and all
essential minerals just by eating well
is zero in the same field for instance
on one farm in the same field rule
number one might have three essential
minerals rule number five might have
zero rule number ten might have eight
row number fifteen might have twenty
rule number twenty might have zero row
number twenty-five may have zero row
number thirty might have sixteen and so
it depends on which row in the field
that your tomato or your corn or your
soybeans or your wheat came from what
minerals you're getting to be happy
plants only need nine minerals we need
sixty and so the plants are happy and
you look at man this is a really
good-looking carrot you know it has nine
minerals but what about the other
fifty-one and doesn't make sense to
throw your life away or at least part of
your longevity or your health on what
may or may not be in the food because
you can't tell by looking at the carrot
as long as it's getting its nine
minerals it's a pea okay then you start
seeing things like this is actually from
nineteen ninety-five healthy crops
depend on healthy saw everybody knows
that need nine minerals but the new
report says that nearly forty percent of
the world's land used for agriculture is
seriously degraded which means it
doesn't have these nutrients in it
anymore
loss of good soil cancer this came out
in 1992 they said that African soils
over the last hundred years in 1992 had
been depleted and its fertility by 74
percent Asia by 73 percent Australia by
55 percent Europe 72 percent the United
States North America 85 percent and
South America by 76 percent I thought
this was kind of interesting this came
out in January of 2000 and this is a
little report and I never have taken the
time to get the original because this is
self-explanatory some blame the
environment USDA says better test a
factor well I think it's more serious
than that they compared a 22 year period
from 1975 to 1997 on certain nutrient
values in her food and they took the ten
most 12 most popular vegetables that are
grown in eaten in America including
broccoli and cabbage carrots cauliflower
collards they can kale mustard greens
onions parsley turnip greens watercress
etc they found out that there was a 53%
drop in the calcium values they found
out there was a 38 percent drop in
vitamin A forty eight percent drop in
riboflavin b2 35 percent less of
thiamine or b1 and a 29 percent less
niacin or vitamin b3 and again the
reason is if you're not putting the
essential minerals in the soil that the
plant needs
slowly slowly their ability to
manufacture vitamins begins to drop
we know that today there's only about 8%
protein in our wheat 19-hundred there's
23 percent protein in our week okay this
is not a mystery that you can prevent
and cure diseases with vitamins minerals
this came out in 1992 cover article Time
magazine the real power of vitamins new
research shows it may help fight cancer
heart disease and the ravages of aging
it was very obvious after writing some
75 scientific articles on on these
diseases that were caused by
deficiencies of vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals and amino acids and
fatty
and animals and people 75 scientific
articles were published in medical
journals and veterinary journals
pathology journals wrote chapters for
eight multi author textbooks on the
subject
what a big textbook of my own big
thousand page textbook trying to educate
medical students was not very successful
at that it was very obvious nothing was
gonna happen so I went back to school
and became a physician in 1978 began to
use these veterinary nutritional
formulas among human patients
and one of the things I wanted to do
special for my patients was to get them
to live to be an average of a hundred
instead of seventy-five so I began to
collect information on what it takes to
live to be a hundred instead of
seventy-five and it's very interesting a
certain percentage of my patients back
then in 1978 would say things like I
don't think I want to live to be 100 I
said well why wouldn't you want to live
to be a hundred well I don't want to
wind up in a nursing home and be abused
and I I thought that was kind of
reasonable concern so I began to collect
information on hundred year olds that
would satisfy me that I was doing the
right thing to help my patients live to
be a hundred this is a sort of evidence
you can find this happens to be from
September 2000 this is a cover of this
particular issue of Scientific American
it's a great little scientific journal
that they use to teach the scientific
method to high school kids and college
students and they write it in the fifth
grade reading level so college students
can understand it and this particular
issue was almost entirely devoted to
human longevity net articles in there by
experts in gerontology and genetics and
nutrition and there was a little summary
at the end to tell you what you were
supposed to learn in this issue and they
were editorially scratching their head
trying to figure out what was going on
because they were trying to find out
what it was it would take people to live
be a hundred and they compared the
people who didn't listen to their
doctors or the people who did listen to
their doctors they found out that the
ones who did not listen to their doctors
live longer the ones who listened to the
doctors
and something we've known for a long
time right so scientifically they
observe that and they found out that the
people who live longer salted their food
ate eggs everyday cooked an eighth with
butter didn't use margarine many of them
smoked many up mate white lining behind
the barn and we're drunk all the time
the only exercise they did when they
came home after work was to fall asleep
on the floor they didn't come home take
a shower and you know go to the fitness
center and they said they ate eggs
instead of ate the egg beaters they used
butter instead of margarine they ate
their chicken skin and they were just
flabbergasted they couldn't figure out
why these people doing all the wrong
things we're living so long
you